chapter 4 portals
every man takes the limits of his own
field of vision for the limits of the
world
arthur schopenhauer being
human boils down to different stages
of consciousness development claire
graves
the most important aspect to the bell
curve distribution
of consciousness evolution are the
portalists
who deploy code updates for the
evolutionary pacer to
upgrade their perception a very famous
recent revolutionary code deployment was
satoshi nakamoto's white paper
which catalyzed the decentralization
revolution
it follows a fascinating style of being
executed pseudonymously
popularizing the idea of stealth updates
to prevent ad hominem
game a consensus reality has an
unsustainable
communal sense-making apparatus which
acts like a bucket of crabs trying to
pull back
the omni-win game b designers trying to
maximize human potential
people like eric and brett weinstein are
fiddlers
on an a-frame roof shooting portals to
higher levels of consciousness
escape the neurotic pacer and find
refuge in genius level mutations
code updates be ashamed
to die until you have won some victory
for humanity horseman
i don't care that they stole my idea
i care that they don't have any of their
own
nikola tesla out of the 100
plus billion people who have lived and
died before us
today we can say approximately one
percent
made profound code updates to
civilization
what are the most salient traits of
these geniuses
abstract out a pattern and systematize
it
approximately 120 years ago the wright
brothers
saw a bird made a plane
and today their genius is thrown away
like a coffee cup
one hundred thousand plus commercial
flights happen
each day on planet earth how many
passengers
contemplate their genius